oh
why hello there people of the internet
i'm person of the internet dave rubin
this
is the reuben report direct message for
march 23rd
2021 before we get to it
click that subscribe button
make sure you're getting notified it'll
show up in your feed
perhaps the videos that is and uh
then we see what happens you know what i
mean then i put on a show you like it
you don't like it you say nice things
about me
you don't like me either way uh it's all
good
uh we are doing three stories today uh
though i quickly want to touch
on the the shooting in boulder colorado
which i'm not going to cover as a story
because there's just so much unfolding
at once but there was a shooting in
boulder colorado last night that you
guys probably all heard about
uh 10 people are dead
we'll find out more okay we'll find out
more you can see everybody's just kind
of running with their narrative i think
the interesting part
of this i mean if you can glean anything
sort of interesting out of these
tragedies
is the way that the blue check
twitterati on twitter
we're all demanding or announcing i
should say
all announcing for the first hour that
this guy was a white supremacist white
supremacist of course
turns out he's an immigrant from syria
now that doesn't mean that all
immigrants from syria are bad people
that's obviously not the case
uh but the the knee-jerk move to
automatically bl
blame white people and white
supremacists on everything
and then the way they oddly backtrack i
mean i've seen social justice warriors
and and woke people today
saying that even though he's an
immigrant from syria he still has
white privilege because he's not that
brown i mean just like the litany
of crazy things anyway we'll probably
cover the story more tomorrow
um but it is one of those ones where
it's like you know the shooting is
horrific and it and it is what it is and
we have to
think about why these things keep
happening and and have an honest
discussion about mental health and
perhaps about guns and education and
culture wars and all that stuff but
unfortunately everybody just kind of
runs to their side and
and treats it as is so the three stories
that we're covering today i saw
a video on twitter yesterday there is a
social justice school
being funded by taxpayer dollars in dc
we're going to show you a little video
and unpack what's going on at this
social justice school and you're not
going to believe it guys
it ain't good it ain't good uh second
story today um
nbc has uh a piece on uh dc statehood
and you may have heard
that in the last couple days there's
been sort of a bigger move really in the
last week it seems like it's picking up
steam
but democrats have been talking about
this for a while that washington d.c
the capital of the country should be a
state now that is not how this
uh the union was formed that's not how
the entire
country and operation was set up with
good reasons which we'll get into
in a little bit so we'll talk about that
but of course if you don't believe
that uh dc should be a state you are a
racist
and we'll get to that too uh and then
finally i wanted to do something
on the pandemic but not really about the
lockdowns or anything else although it's
tangentially there
um you know the the stress the stress
and depression
and rates of alcoholism and all that
which i've talked about a little bit
over the last couple months uh there's a
new pew poll that
really sort of unpacks what young people
are going through
what people at different socioeconomic
stratas are
dealing with and and it's messy it's
pretty messy so we're going to get
to all of that and i'll try not to bring
up hitler or drop the f-bomb today that
is the goal uh but before we do any of
that let's talk
to you about built bar you know it's not
often that you get to put the words
healthy
and delicious in the same sentence
together so if you've been struggling to
keep that new year's resolution to get
healthier
i'm about to bring some really good news
to you it's called built bar
and it's the rare item of food
got one right here uh that's both hi
healthy and delicious built bar
is high in protein and fiber and low in
calories and carbs
each bar contains between 110 and 160
calories
up to 20 grams of protein and you only
get three to five net carbs
so you can even do this keto if you want
and meanwhile it's made with real
chocolate and tastes amazing
this is the kind of snack that's going
to allow you to lose or maintain weight
while indulging in something delicious
and that's
always a welcome change bill bars have a
ton of amazing flavors like caramel
brownie cookies and cream
peanut butter mint brownie and a lot
more i've got several of them on my desk
right now
don't give up your new year's resolution
built bar is the answer go to built
bar not billbar go to builtbar.com and
use promo code ruben to get 15
off your next order use promo code ruben
for 15 off at builtbar.com
all right so the first story i wanted to
cover for you guys uh apparel so i saw
this video
on twitter yesterday but apparently
since
august of 2020 there has been a new
charter school
in the dc area called the social justice
public charter school it is funded with
taxpayer money
and you're not going gonna believe this
guys they're up to some pretty
funky stuff over there so we're gonna
show you a video this is from i believe
a zoom
chat between the president of the school
who's the gentleman
and uh the woman there who's in charge
of science and wellness at the school
and i just want you to listen
to some of the things that they're
saying and remember this is funded
at least partly by taxpayer dollars
what i think of is equity and i think
about
the ways in which we can dismantle an
oppressive system
um with our kids you know what i'm
saying not for them we're doing it with
them we're
we're using you know they they are a
gateway um
to getting free to getting um to being
liberating to
to changing the system from something
that is meant to keep us down to
something that we're being able to
flourish in
oh lordy lordy she gave me a lot of good
buzzwords there
um first off the school is designed to
dismantle
an oppressive system the system
apparently is so oppressive that it'll
allow you
to make a charter school to do just that
funded by
pat by taxpayer dollars i mean that's uh
that's pretty bananas right there
of course she says some of the other
things that i'm always talking about
equity
equity equity which as you guys know
equity is
the most dangerous word in our lexicon
right now it is the it is the worst
idea being packaged as a good idea the
idea that we will all end
up in the same place it's anti-human it
takes away all of your
individual autonomy your ability to work
hard or not work hard to come from a
good family or not come from a good
family
to have a little bit of luck in life if
we're just gonna have a system
that makes everybody equitable all we
can do is give
people equal rights and that's what
we've done in this country
um and she wants to dismantle right
so we talked about the dismantling the
equity uh
so this is what's happening there uh
let's show their uh
logo with a little bit of the text there
uh
be part of the solution as a community
we will do our
part to make sure that the murders of
black lives at the hands of law
enforcement will not be in vain
now is the time for a revolutionary
social justice
middle school all right so the reason i
wanted to do this story right now
is because as i said there was the the
shooting happened and i was like you
know i don't want to just
dive right into that let's let's wait
and see i know that's kind of crazy but
like let's wait and see until we have
a little bit more information and then i
saw this and it's like
this type of thing gets to sort of the
root of almost everything we're talking
about here all the time
how the state is now funding
things that will be racist do you think
that a middle schooler who goes to that
school who learns that america is this
oppressive patriarchy
who learns that equity is better than
equality
who learns a series of things that are
counter
to all of our founding documents and all
that and and to dismantle
the very things that allow them to live
freely do you think they're going to
come out as a more tolerant person or
not do you think they're going to come
out as a more enlightened person
as as someone that's going to you know
sort of fight to get theirs
in society or someone that's going to
burn it all down and that
those things cannot be decoupled from
each other
there is a reason that these people that
the people that push this set of ideas
have been so unable to really build
anything right
black lives matter has made billions of
dollars it's unclear
where any of that money has gone antifa
has caused at least roughly two billion
dollars worth of damage like if they
wanted to bring on
their communist revolution or something
wouldn't they be building schools
wouldn't black lives matter
be sending young people to you know
historically black colleges whatever
whatever you want to do
but they're not good at that so what
they're good at doing is dismantling
things mean
meaning destroy things and it is much
easier
to destroy things than to build things
the school slogan by the way is where
scholar
meets activists that's that's very
dangerous that's very dangerous i really
think about it for just
a second think about all your teachers
growing up whether you went to a public
school
or a private school or half and half
whatever it is that you did
or whether you were homeschooled even
would you want your
scholar so in essence your teacher where
your teacher
meets activist that's dangerous you
don't want a teacher to be an activist
and i assume i don't know if they're
saying where scholar meets activist
meaning that's what the teacher should
be as one thing
or the scholar meets activists meaning
they're actually breeding
an entire group of activists that's
probably that one
but that's dangerous these kids should
learn to
understand that two plus two is four
that there are basic truths that america
is good that enlightenment values are
worth conserving
and all of these things and i suspect
that's not going to happen and it's
being paid for
by the public so this is another one of
those moments where
you know my book which is back there
uh you know i lay out all of the what i
believe are the other classically
liberal principles that are the right
way to run a society and i believe those
to be the best ways to do it
one thing i've hedged on since the
probably
11 months or so 10 months that the book
has come out
is that i used to really be for public
education or at least
a role for the government in public
education i went to
public elementary school junior high
high school i went to a public
state university of new york at
binghamton which was a great school at
the time probably not so great anymore
i thought there was a role for
government in education but it's
becoming harder and harder
to push that narrative right like if you
know that your kids look the people that
go to this charter school they're
selecting them into the school so they
know what they're getting they're
basically signing their kids up
to be brainwashed but if you send your
kids to just the local public school and
these bad ideas and the ideas of
critical race theory and everything else
get in there and then they start hating
themselves because of their skin color
or they start judging people
because of their skin color which is the
reverse of that martin luther king guy
but we got to get rid of him soon enough
so anyway it's pretty bananas and it's
worth paying attention to these types of
things because it's like
all right so there's one social justice
charter school now
it's in dc do you think that's going to
be the last one i
suspect not uh okay let's move on
uh you know there's been this big push
in the last couple weeks to get
dc washington dc to be
a state and you're not going to believe
it but the narrative seems to be forming
that if you don't believe that dc should
be a state just because
they believe it now and it might have
something to do with they want extra
electoral college votes and they're
really
trying to wrap this thing up nicely so
no republican can ever win again um
but if you don't buy into what they're
saying uh of course
you are a racist so nbc ran a story the
dc
statehood fight is part of an ugly
effort
to disenfranchise black and brown people
yes i'm shocked people that the
mainstream media would frame something
around racism when it has absolutely
nothing to do with racism but you know
they'll find a way to do it and let's
look at the sub headline
battles for statehood have always been
political but they've
also quite often but they've but they've
also quite often
about race i think we might have a loss
to word there but they've also quite
often been about race i suppose
uh washington dc's fight for recognition
is no different and then directly from
the article itself
withholding statehood from the district
of columbia is part of a
far more sinister nationwide effort to
disenfranchise
non-white americans at disproportionate
rates it goes on today non-white
americans are
are more likely to be purged from voter
rolls more likely to live in
gerrymandered vote
sinks where elections are effectively
decided by maps and not voters
more likely to endure horrifically long
lines to vote
when they can at all these efforts to
minimize the impact of non-white votes
whether motivated by cynical part
partisanship or explicit white supremacy
are a legacy of the most shameful part
of american
history okay well i'm going to explain
to you in just a minute
uh via a piece in the federalist why dc
was set up not to be a state in the
first place
now look i'm not saying there aren't
some issues might there be some issues
with gerrymandering
there might be might there be some
issues with the way we vote do you think
maybe there are some issues with the way
we vote and the fact that when i went
to vote for president here and i
actually took out my wallet because i
was going to show the woman
my id she was like no no no you don't
need it like anyone
can vote there's also this meme out
there i keep seeing this thing now i saw
it
this morning it was really out there
that somehow it's easier to get a gun
than to vote in america and it's like
no i literally walked in to vote i could
have been anybody
and then just walked right back in and
been anybody else i have bought some
guns
here in los angeles in the last six
months and it is not easy to get them
and it takes weeks and there's
background checks
and a whole series of other things um
but let's let's jump to uh
to the federalist uh for an explanation
as to why dc was set up not to be a
state and then we'll unpack a little bit
the founders intended for the capital of
the newly created united states to be a
neutral ground
for co-equal sovereign states to come
together
to transact the nation's business at the
time state
governments were much more powerful than
they are today so a worry about placing
the capital within a state
was that the state might exercise unfair
influence or pressure
on the federal government granting d.c
statehood
would put the other 50 states at a
distinct disadvantage
when looking to influence federal policy
grants and regulation
okay so we could go much more into that
and actually let's do a show
about dc statehood in general all right
so we'll do a full show on that and
maybe
unpacking a little bit more of sort of
the nuts and bolts uh
as to why the founders set things up the
way that they did but what i think is
particularly
interesting with that is that they set
up
this system because they were trying to
decentralize power right that was the
whole idea we have 50 states
then there's this thing where they can
all come together and fight it out and
if one of them that's what i just read
here if one of them has too much power
and that's the one where this thing is
now we got a problem so we all know that
the world is going towards
decentralization right like we know that
the tech world is going there it's
fairly obvious that the education world
almost everything i think in the future
will be decentralized if
if human life is to remain free on
planet earth which i suppose is a little
bit of an if these days
um so when the people now want dc
statehood and of course they're going to
tell you it's racist if you don't want
it
right it's racist if you don't want it
do you think any of these workstars or
any progressive or democrat
would want dc to be a state if there was
any chance that it could be read
like are they really doing this because
they just want to make sure that these
disenfranchised voters
get a chance to vote or is it do you
think and call me cynical here
do you think it's possible that actually
what they're doing
is a really awful ploy because they
know that it will be blue it will not be
read and it will enshrine them in power
forever i know i know dave you're such a
cynic i get it people
i get it um anyway
whether dc should be a state or not it
is not it was never based
in racism has our history been a little
bit messy
yes have we done an incredible amount to
make it much much much much better
yes we have which is why all of the
people
the woman in that video i showed you a
moment ago she doesn't want to leave
america she wants to dismantle america
because she doesn't want to go anywhere
else because nowhere else is better
there is no
place better than this place there's no
place like home that's what dorothy said
and there's no place better than this
thing so when these people when they
want to
make dc estate and they want to change
the filibuster
and they want to pack the courts all
things that at some
level might make some sense perhaps
but do you think they're doing it
because they want things to be
freer and fairer and more people to be
welcomed into the system or do you think
they're doing it because they want
to have more control over the system
because they want to have their hand on
every lever of power
again i know call me a cynic but
that's what i think all right let's
shift all together and let's talk a
little bit about what's going on with
lockdowns and just sort of the
psychological distress that that people
are dealing with you know we know that
rates of alcoholism are up i'm sure you
guys have versions of this in your
family i just saw a study
the other day that that um obesity is on
the rise
like there's just everyone's kind of
nutty you know like i think you probably
know people that like
sort of came out of covid now that we're
sort of deciding it's over
it's like some people kind of came out
better
and some people really did come out
worse and it's not always their fault
and it could be your
age and what other stresses you have and
losing your job and all of these things
but i've been saying for a long time
since this started we have no idea what
kind of ramifications
this year of locked away craziness is
going to do
you know the idea that like if you were
a high school kid
and last year was your last year to play
whatever your
favorite sport was you know you were
starting point guard on the basketball
team and they just stole your last
year away or you were a girl in the band
or you were a trans wrestler
at the women's wrestling event or
whatever whatever it is
that young people were were doing last
year it was taken away from them and of
course
a lot of stuff was taken away from
adults too and the idea that we trained
ourselves to just sort of listen to the
experts and then the experts get things
wrong and then
we get lost having to decipher any
sensible anything from the media it's a
it's a big freaking mess so anyway
pugh did a research poll on american
trends
this is from february 16th to 21st among
about 10
000 americans to sort of get a sense of
where people are at
psychologically right now i've got a
quote from pew
experts have documented that fear and
isolation associated with the pandemic
have been responsible for a surge of
anxiety
and depression over the past year yeah
and we're seeing a ton of this with
young people
it goes on to say young people have been
a particular group of concern during the
pandemic
for mental health professionals and
young adults stand out
in the current survey for exhibiting
higher levels of psychological distress
than other age groups
the shutdowns have disrupted job
opportunities college experience
and the mixing and mingling that marks
the transition
to adulthood among those interviewed
in the current survey who say that the
pandemic is a major threat to their
personal financial situation
34 are classified as being
in high psychological distress so i'm
going to throw to two
two charts in just a sec but you can
already see what's going on here when
when you take away everything that's
normal it's one thing
for an adult to have to adjust right so
like
this last year was crazy for everybody
for my team and trying to figure out
i'll just i'm just going to give myself
as an example right and we all remember
that beginning of kovid
when it was like really we were thinking
like is is the world
over and you're you're going to
supermarkets with you know rubber gloves
on and all of the craziness
and we've moved to complete remote work
and we had to put a satellite on my
house and a whole bunch of
other stuff and we had to hire people
and we had to spend a lot of money on
new equipment and
and all sorts of stuff but fortunately
for me our our business has thrived in
the middle of
this entire situation and and oddly we
were positioned pretty well because
i was sort of doing it all from home
first right so now
everybody's kind of doing it from home
and i we were sort of ahead of the game
um but that doesn't mean that everyone
was that lucky and i do view myself as
as being lucky i was sort of ahead of
the curve on this stuff
but it's still a stroke of luck that
that things turned out to be okay
but now they take away your job now
you're 15 they take away a year of your
dating life
right a year where you can hang out with
your friends and you should just be
in your house with your parents and you
should just be on zoom all day and
everything else
so let's let's throw up the first chart
here because there's there's some
interesting stuff here
uh so this is about one-third of u.s
adults report at least occasional
sleeplessness anxiety in the past week
so the number that i thought was
interesting there is the top right
if you see that that 31 and the 17 in
the top right so that means that
basically if you add 31 plus 17 that
means that
48 of
uh young people in the u.s adults
felt hopeful about the future well only
a little of the time or less than one
day of the time do they feel hopeful
so basically half the people in america
according to this
study don't feel hopeful more than one
day a week
that's a real problem that's a real
problem that means we've got
you know you can all picture that old
commercial like the depression
commercial remember that woman was like
wandering around and there was this like
cartoon like blob following her and it
was the depression that was following
her
well i think everyone sort of has that
like people don't feel like there's a
vision for the future that makes sense
the entire sense making apparatus the
entire public intellectual
exercise has just absolutely collapsed
let's just look again at this see a
couple others
so you can see like a whole bunch of
people are having trouble sleeping
uh people are feeling depressed nervous
and anxious
um had a physical reaction when thinking
about the outbreak
25 of adults said that
most of the time five to seven days they
have
some sort of physical reaction you know
i can tell you that that physical
reactions related to stress
are real you guys know when when i was
when this show started taking off and i
started getting the crazy hate and the
hit pieces
and being called the white supremacist
and it's all old hat to me now
but when that first started happening to
me years ago i
internalized my stress i wasn't dealing
with it well i developed alopecia areata
which is an autoimmune disease and i
lost
huge huge chunks of my hair this is all
it's all mine now
um but i talk about this in the book but
i lost huge chunks of hair
and it was because of stress so people
can get all sorts of things because of
stress the the
you know there's just so much happening
here so let's let's jump to the other
chart
uh because this is more focused on uh
young adults and especially women
so what i thought was interesting here
is that right now women
ages 18 to 29 36
of them say that they're in high
distress
men are at 27 that's too much too but 36
of young women young 18 to 29 year old
women who are about to enter the prime
of their lives you know i like to think
as a 44 year old that the 40s are really
the prime of your life because the 20s
it's like
you know you don't know what's going on
you can just do everything and you know
you're never tired
30s you're kind of getting it all in
order 40s is where it can sort of
crystallize so i like to think i'm kind
of right in the middle of that
but these 18 to 29 year olds 27
of men 36 of women are in high distress
and then uh the the column right but uh
beneath that
also 18 to 29 depending on income lower
income
people almost 40 percent 39
feel that they're in high distress it's
almost
as if going to work and getting a
paycheck
and feeling like a productive member of
society is an important thing
it's almost as if the government just
taking tax money from you so that it can
give you less money back
every now and again and then you know
pat you on the head
you good little pet that maybe that's
not the best way to be doing things
it's almost as if these things i point i
really am cynical today
uh and let's just look at one other um
18 to 29 marital status
i thought this was interesting too so 23
of married people
feel that they're in high distress 35
of unmarried people and the reason i
thought that was interesting was because
look what's happened in in the world of
dating in the last year i know one
person one person who was single when
this thing started
met someone on zoom they fell in love
and now lived together
took less than a year i know one person
like that but imagine i've talked to
many of my friends who are single if you
imagine if you were just single
picture in new york city so you're
single in new york city you're basically
everything's locked down you can't go
out to bars you can't
go out to restaurants or you know maybe
you can you're wearing masks there's no
there's no more like walking up to
somebody at a bar right like you can't
just walk up to somebody at a bar
because they don't want you standing at
the bar right so you can put a mask on
the way they have just disassembled all
of our
ability to just be normal is going to
have so many long lasting effects i am
telling you guys when i walk my dog it's
not just that they
people literally pull their dogs away as
if the dogs are going to infect each
other
i now go out of my way this is not a
joke i go out of my way to give the most
over-the-top hellos to people when we
first moved here you know i don't love
the idea that people could know where i
live so i usually got my hat and glasses
now i have a mask i look you know i'm
gonna rob a bank
but now it's gotten to the point where
people just walk by you and they don't
even acknowledge that another human is
there so i'm
hey how you doing what's going on nice
to see you good morning how are you good
well good evening
what's going on what's happening nice to
see you oh you're having a good day i
mean i am completely over the top now
and people they often they won't even
look at you they won't even look and
they're still walking around with masks
and everything else so getting out of
this thing like
you know i know that uh that elderly man
joe biden said that on july 4th we might
be able to get
together with a small amount of family
in the backyard if we're good
to celebrate america's independence
which is completely bananas
um but there is going to be so much
stuff
that we have to deal with after this and
um
and actually that's one of the reasons
why i'm i'm so proud of what we've done
with the reuben report locals community
because we're creating community again
because community has been decimated
because of this thing and we're doing it
without trolls and bots so if you want
to join us
of course somehow turned into a product
placement but i didn't mean it to go
there but
as you know it is
reubenreport.locals.com by the way guys
part one of my interview with
uh british actor lawrence fox
who almost got canceled about a year ago
he has just such a freaking fascinating
story this guy he almost got cancelled
basically for being a good old-fashioned
liberal he considers himself a classical
liberal
had never been called racist until a
year ago and then he was on a british tv
show and all hell broke loose that
really put him on the map
and what i love about this guy is that
you know i keep saying this idea that
i'm tired of people who just talk
i want people who do like you gotta go
do something go build a tech company go
start a political party go
build a product whatever it is well he
actually did it and he started the
reclaim party
in the uk and because they want to
reclaim liberalism pretty sweet
and and he's running for mayor against
the d khan who is the far left
woke progressive mayor of london who's
completely ruining that city so part one
with lawrence fox
up now on youtube the full episode is up
uh ad free
already at reubenreport.locals.com oh
and since we did a little education
stuff
this morning on the top of the show uh
this friday we have a
panel three guests plus me four human
beings all the little boxes
and it's all about education and how we
can fix the system all right everybody
have a great day
i'll see you tomorrow and uh you know
it's okay it's gonna be all right